what are your dreams
i've always wanted to know what it was
like to actually sink in quicksand
uh get blown to safety one of them
that's such a great 80s movie thing
where like the explosion happens on you
and then you're like rocketed into like
a like a body of water
i guess the trick to being blown to
safety really is
a how flexible is your spine right
because you're gonna
you know what i mean when it hits you ah
you get you know depending on if it's
from the front of the back but either
way your spine's gonna go like that okay
so that's number one number two is
what's your tolerance for shrapnel
yeah that's right that's right well you
gotta you know because the shrapnel
hopefully is blown around you but not
directly into you yeah yeah you've got a
couple pieces in you is there something
soft you can land into when you're blown
to bits that's right is there right is
there a mattress truck going by just as
you get yeah yeah truck full of chicken
feathers or like